wish things were different
[Music]
I was thankful different
le but a king
[Music]
please dub
[Music]
I'm leaving tomorrow
to do this smart we believe in Jackson
vulnerable
so they just get to get away with this
how'd you find us
[Music]
you can't stop this not at any cost
[Music]
I really hope you make it
[Music]
I have to finish it there's a cost
[Music]
we could have killed you maybe you
should have
[Music]
i'm neil druckmann vice president of nya
dog and the director of the last of us
part two we're just a few weeks away
from launch on June 19th when the game
will finally be in your hands the wait
has been long and we're extremely
grateful for your patience especially
now in the midst of these unprecedented
and challenging times we hope you're all
taking care of yourselves and that you
your friends and your loved ones are
doing well because of these
extraordinary circumstances we can't be
together in this final stretch and share
the experience like we usually would so
today we're trying something different
something we've never done before
over the next 20 minutes or so we're
going to give you an in-depth look into
what awaits you in the Last of Us part 2
including new details about the gameplay
experience and story and to cap it all
off we'll be showing a never-before-seen
lengthy gameplay sequence you'll
definitely want to stick around for that
I don't know what happened they're
supposed to take her to the fireflies
and walk away
they were actually gonna make it cure
the only catch it would kill her The
Last of Us part 2 picks up Ellie and
Joel story several years after the
events of the first game Ellie and Joel
have settled in Jackson Wyoming amongst
a thriving community of survivors with
the threats of the world kept outside
the town's walls Jackson has been able
to find relative peace and even
stability Ellie is now 19 lives in her
own and has been able to forge lasting
relationships within the community scale
of one to ten
how would you
great our kiss from last night
[Music]
however this piece is short-lived
Jackson and Ellie suffer a violent and
traumatizing event Ellie sets off back
into the treacherous outside world in
search of retribution and justice her
journey will take her to new parts of
the country previously unexplored in the
Last of Us the story spans multiple
seasons and climates from the
snow-capped mountains of Jackson to the
lush Pacific Northwest
each introduces a wide range of exterior
and interior environments for you to
navigate and explore rendered in
meticulous detail and unprecedented
scale with the latest iteration of the
Naughty Dog Engine our goal was to make
these environments not only beautiful
but feel as grounded and authentic to
the cities they're based on as possible
much of the story unfolds in what
remains of Seattle a massive former
quarantine zone its locales are
incredibly diverse spanning a dense city
center with a skyline of towering
high-rises to the beautiful suburbs and
stormy water fronts that surround it
the city exhibits drastic shifts in
architecture elevation and weather and
with part two we've introduced new
traversal mechanics that afford greater
exploration and ways to navigate threats
le is not only able to climb and jump
over gaps but she can use ropes to scale
vertical terrain or swing over obstacles
allowing you to discover new areas
resources and side narratives these more
open environments also create new
strategic considerations in combat
whether it's to get the jump on enemies
or bypass them entirely the Las Olas
part 2 features some of the largest
environments we've ever created
horseback riding will allow Ellie to
quickly cover some of these expansive
terrains some streets are so flooded
that a boat is required to navigate
however the world of the last of us is
as lush and inviting as it is deadly
Ezeli uncovers the path to finding those
who have wronged her she must face the
many threats of this unknown city in the
wake of the pandemic and the fall of the
quarantine zone Seattle has become a
warzone where two warring factions find
themselves in an ongoing conflict for
territory and resources
one of these groups is their Washington
Liberation Front otherwise known as the
W LF the W LF our militia group that
began as resistance to the military
occupation of Seattle and eventually
wrestled control the city from them they
are highly trained organized and well
equipped with weapons they stole from
the army they occupy much of the city
imprisoning or killing trespassers on
sight on the other side of this bloody
conflict is a group of religious zealots
called the Sara fights or scars defined
by the self inflicted deep cuts that
they bear across their faces like the W
left are deeply tribalistic and
territorial they're known for being
stealthy using overgrowth as cover and
they use more silent weapons like bows
and arrows clip her wings
but beyond this conflict among survivors
the threat that originally brought the
world to its knees is very much present
every human is in danger of falling
victim to the infected there are the
recently infected runners who are more
numerous and aggressive than escaped the
blind but extremely deadly Clippers and
the stalkers who sneak and hide until
they're ready to attack surprising their
victim of extreme agility and brutal
violence the Last of Us part 2
introduces new stages of infected such
as the Chandler's large heavily armored
enemies that are covered in pustules
upon getting close to you they expel a
corrosive spore cloud burns its victims
but our most terrifying and lethal new
forms of infected will have to wait
until you play the game for yourselves
overcoming these threats will require
careful consideration of how you
approach every combat encounter and how
you leverage Ellie's unique skills
equipment and environment to your
advantage something the WLF patrolled
the streets of Seattle with guard dogs
which are capable of detecting and
following you even while uncovered you
think this guy's connected to they can
pick up your scent and alert their
handlers to your presence listen mode
will reveal your scent trail keep moving
and cause distractions to avoid
detection 25 years after the pandemic
began the world has completely overgrown
use tall grass to hide from enemies and
go prone to stay out of sight however
this form of analogue stealth means
you're never fully hidden if enemies get
close enough they can discover you even
ingress when Ellie is overwhelmed
running aways a viable option you can
also break glass or crawl through tight
spaces to find new paths or areas to
evade or take on your enemies in any
given combat situation you can flee an
encounter and re-establish stealth to
regain the advantage if you absolutely
have to fight your way out there are a
variety of tools at your disposal
Ellie's more agile and most of her
enemies she can sprint and quickly dodge
incoming attacks learning how opponents
attack with different weapons and
mastering the timing of your dodges will
prevent you from taking damage and
create opportunities to counter-attack
you can use throw ball items or
well-placed shots to stun enemies before
dealing a killing blow
or using them as a shield to protect
yourself or buy some time to figure out
your next one Ellie isn't always alone
on her journey allies will take part in
helping you navigate the environments
spot enemies and meaningfully help you
in combat encounters
between the human survivors and the
roaming infected there will be times
where multiple threats are present
creating new strategic considerations
and opportunities you can choose whether
to attack these opponents separately and
directly or find ways to pit them
against each other please they fight or
wait until their numbers have thinned
out and engaged with whoever's left
our goal is to create unparallel
attention
coupled with deep systems that give you
greater control and influence over your
journey as you play you'll be able to
invest in the broad collection of
crafting items weapon and player
upgrades through training manual
scattered throughout the environment and
scavenging for ingredients these skills
and upgrade manuals cater to a variety
of play styles and the choices you make
will create your own distinct experience
we also wanted to extend that agency and
personalization to your weapons to our
new workbench systems scavenger parts to
modify and improve your weapons
performance and attributes all of which
are visualized and become part of your
character
[Music]
[Music]
survival will also require using the
parts and ingredients that you'll find
an environment which can be crafted into
a wide range of defensive and offensive
items like proximity mines explosive
arrows pistol suppressors and more
[Music]
all of these gameplay systems are meant
to immerse you in the world and make you
feel and lockstep with Ellie's emotional
journey as we've said before this is
Naiya dog's largest most ambitious game
it may seem like we cover a lot but we
only scratch the surface of what it's
like to play The Last of Us part two we
can't wait for you to experience at all
for yourself on June 19th
until then here's an extended sequence
of never-before-seen gameplay and joy
[Music]
did you find her yet Isaac's not happy
[Music]
escape [ __ ] early talking about don't
make a [ __ ] sound hands up
you know a girl named Nora where is she
we're in the hospital they're clearing
out the upper floors she's somewhere in
there
word is we're almost wrapped up good I
got my girl waiting for you [ __ ] me they
put you with your dares hey we get the
job done I bet you do oh this is not
fair I'm telling you man
theta soldier who makes these shifts so
much easier
I'll keep that in mind [ __ ] sounds like
scars are getting closer that's our guys
executing those freaks
hey I heard that Isaac wants us to
retake all of downtown
I heard it might take you quite to then
oh no way not after what went down last
time
even Isaac isn't that crazy that's what
I heard
all right
[Music]
just like that
[Music]
[Music]
I'll go check it out
[Music]
[Music]
that you Nora
[Music]
we hear that's stupid
you're gonna tell us where she went when
Isaac talks to us about this I'm getting
tired of this Nora Nora I'm not going
down for her man
don't scream
[Music]
put that [ __ ] down
[Music]
you remember me he remember me
[Music]